welcome back so Eric Ries is well
everyone knows right he's the author in
the creator of the Lean Startup which is
a true phenomenon in the valley and in
in the world of business these days and
we're really happy to have you and to be
able to talk to you for a few minutes
about kind of the experience of the Lean
Startup one thing I want to get at is
just start off where did this idea this
kind of synthesis that you that you
pulled off in the book and and on the
blog that the book spawned from where
did all these ideas that you kind of
drew together come from well first of
all thank you for having me and hi
everybody
I mean really we've already hear this
story this theme all day it came from
failure and I know you know when you're
a professional expert you're not
supposed to say things like this but
just as a matter of disclaimer almost
every single product I have ever built
or worked on in my whole career has been
a colossal failure it's like if you
follow me you too can be a colossal
failure that's why you don't say things
like that but that's the truth and you
know so if I there's no way I would be
doing what I'm doing now if I had gotten
lucky and any of those products had
really been successful and so I was
always I was an engineer by training you
know I was a programmer and I always
thought that better technology would
yield better results better impact more
whatever so I was always looking for
technical solutions to what was actually
a very human problem that most of these
products that I built although they are
technically excellent are not actually
being used by anybody even as we speak
you know sitting on a shelf somewhere in
disuse if that if there was a technical
solution to that problem believe me I
would have been very happy to discover
it but so I tried you know pulling ideas
in from agile software development and
trying to you know improve the
architecture improve the agility of the
organizations I worked at and yet none
of those ideas were really helping and
so I had to kind of go beyond what was
considered a technical problem and start
to get into how do we figure out what it
is that customers actually want how do
we figure out as a start-up that doesn't
even know who our customer is how do we
figure out what what quality means
are we making progress are we learning
things that are important and so I was
really searching for you know I figured
I would just go read the book on that
topic and then I would know what to do
and it didn't exist and so I was really
you know struggling trying to find ideas
that would be helpful and you know I
call it Lean Startup to acknowledge the
debt from lean manufacturing which was
the first kind of comprehensive theory
of something that made sense kind of
comported with my kind of intuitive
sense of what I was seeing it helped me
make sense of the crazy stuff that was
happening in the startups I worked at
right so when I want to get into the
kind of nuances and framework of what
the lean startup constitutes but um but
one of your first failures was there
comm which was we were just talking
about it backstage and it was it was
fascinating because it was such a big
deal at the time it was it was this
massive it was a kind of classic
2003-2004 big lots of money lots of big
supporters very talented staff thank you
um and and it kind of was this virtual
community that they viewed to an
audience of that people zero audience
right yeah didn't respond to it which
which is yeah yes I drew a 100% true yes
but but as you said the people who were
working on were really talented and they
went on to do all these great things and
oh yeah the insight was was the kind of
experience that that was was vast
absolute look I mean the total valuation
and kind of value creation of all of the
startups founded by X they're people I
mean I must probably a billion dollars
by now I mean really very talented
people have gone on to do amazing things
cuz we all shared a really important
lesson and what not to do when I look
back and look it's failure is really
painful and the big embarrassing failure
is more than anything else I mean it's I
cringe thinking about it's like it's
such a depressing episode the very first
startup I did I got to have what I like
to call the first half of the movie The
Social Network experience so an Ivy
League university you know in my dorm
building a startup all our friends and
you know how in the movies when you do
startups there's all those like wise
people who tell you it's not going to
work and like the most satisfying part
of the movie at the end is when you get
to tell those people that they were
wrong you know it did work but like so
we've got to visualize having to go back
to all those people and be like yeah you
were
you I should not have done that didn't
didn't work out so I mean I had an
expensive dot-com bubble kind of
experience in college with luckily the
bubble burst
you know before I could get into much
trouble and company failed and then I
did this huge Silicon Valley you know
massive huge launch tons of prominent
VCS and I you know I was not the founder
that was a junior person involved in
that company and what was so interesting
was it was basically the same failure as
the one I had done as a student only two
orders of magnitude more expensive but
still the bay same basic concept we just
assumed we knew what customers would
want and acted as if our plan was you
know had been passed down to us by some
kind of divine inspiration and that yeah
it's and we were talking the spec stage
the problem with these stories of
failure is it because as the audience
you already know that this company was a
failure everything I say about it will
make me sound like an idiot
they're like well I can't believe they
ever believed that people would do it
doesn't matter what it is you know and
and the first coming building well
coming I built in my dorm just to be
clear was a company for college students
and Ivan the universities to create
online profiles for the purpose of
sharing but that's where not to be a
pretty good idea but we wanted to help
students get jobs because we want to
build a real business so right they're
like what an idiot I can't believe right
I understand it's in pop because you
know the outcome it's impossible to
really wrap your mind around the fact
that when you are actually in a startup
when you are an entrepreneur when it's
your idea everything you experience
makes you think the idea is better and
better and better so every person you
just you get constant positive
confirmation because that's just what we
are as human beings we fall in love with
ideas and you know what I have learned
to do and to try and teach other people
to do it's just just not it's okay to
create that reality distortion field
it's just every once in a while we want
to step outside it for a moment and just
double check that actually what we're
doing is in fact brilliant and we're not
just driving a car off a cliff so just
just I'm sure you're right those of you
who I know this doesn't apply to you
because your ideas brilliant I
understand but even you who have the
most Brooke just maybe double check just
just a little bit so but one of the
things you're doing with Lean Startup is
basically to take those experiences and
and minimize the I mean there's lots of
risk in startups or I did it yeah it is
intrinsic to the task but
you're you're minimizing the likelihood
of failure or them you're minimizing the
kind of exposure to failure by by these
kind of rules that you set and these are
the these are the rules that have become
you know ubiquitous and and and probably
painful you hear a little bit but things
like you know the the iteration iterate
and iterate fast pivot so pivot pivot is
if you like that a company doesn't work
then quickly change your company and do
something else and the minimum viable
product or MVP which is sometimes just
putting an idea out there not not an
actual product but an idea of what the
product might be and seeing if anybody
responds to it that's that's minimizing
the risk quite a bit you don't even have
a product you're just saying you do yeah
yeah absolutely and when you recognize
that the sounds all sounds very
straightforward because you know that
the logic of this is to be like look the
core problem of a start-up is you don't
know who your customer are is you don't
know if you're on the path to a
sustainable business he all these
problems so the unit of progress in a
startup is learning what we call any
sort of validated learning scientific
proven learning that you actually are
know what you're talking about
and so if and that sounds pretty good
most entrepreneurs at that point are
like yeah who's not for learning I'm
everyone's for learning but if we say no
no that is the unit of progress anything
else you do that doesn't contribute to
learning actually is a form of waste
including building too robust of a
product launching it too big in the
press I mean launching the press classic
sign of a startup that's about to fail I
wish to get the press right about that
would be great anyway sorry those things
are waste
they don't actually help you learn
because if a hundred customers don't
like your product then what does it
matter what the hundred and first
customer doesn't like your product
what's the learning value of the
thousandth customer of the hundred
thousandth and so a lot of the companies
I've built failed so spectacularly not
because the technology wasn't good or
didn't work because we literally
couldn't get anybody even to try it to
tell us how bad it was okay but that's
the kind of failure that's the clot and
it was when we talk about well
oftentimes the Minimum Viable Product is
simply an experiment that allows
customers to sign up you know would you
even have to create page to where you
apologize the products not available yet
not if nobody signs up and and that's
the most common case actually is that
you can't even get anyone to find
doubt that you haven't built the product
yet and I understand not your idea right
that's the problem I understand when you
are in it it seems impossible but that's
what we're trying to do is not people
and people get really fixated on the
parts of Lean Startup that fit on a
bumper sticker
okay the bumper sticker bits of our
people's favorite parts pivot sorry
about that
MVP I know it's very tight iteration you
go on YouTube is a very funny video
where there's a Lean Startup expert is
trying to convince a drug dealer they
need to iterate more like it's gotten
out of control I understand though the
bumper sticker stuff people love but the
heart of it is trying to apply the
scientific method to the process of
entrepreneurship itself so that whatever
you have to do as an entrepreneur that
will help you learn faster that's what
you do and sometimes that's as simple as
a landing page experiment sometimes it's
more complicated and you know tactics
are not what we're trying to teach we're
trying to teach this set of principles
about learning and measuring the right
things right so this started I it's a
kind of classic story classic success
story viewers it started as a blog you
had these ideas you had this experience
you had kind of crystallize this notion
you had the blog and you had a fervent
following on the blog and then you
decided through a new book yeah and I
love this moment that you describe in a
blog post where you the book is
available all this hard work is is kind
of come to fruition and the book is
available on pre-order on Amazon yeah
and so you you you announced your your
blog followers that it's number 3,000 or
something and if they can please order
the book it would be great
and then you have an update and you come
back to look at Amazon again and all of
a sudden it's at number three on Amazon
which we must have been an amazing
vindication and come and for the record
number one and number two or both george
RR martin because publisher at packaged
is all his old books in two separate SKU
from the new book i thought that was
totally cheating it's not fair you're
not gonna beat Game of Thrones right
that's not fair so yeah really sure but
no I'm just kidding now that I take it
personally but I've never been so
overwhelmed it was incredible there was
an incredible thing and that was that
the moment when you knew that you all of
a sudden had something that was much
bigger than something in Silicon Valley
but something that resonated much larger
you know that would make a really good
story I wish that was the limit no no I
mean right I got to feel like gosh oh
that's such a good thank you for teeing
that up that would be such a good story
but the truth of these things
is actually always more boring than will
make a good story and the truth is by
that time I already knew because the
reason that pitch was so successful in
getting order to people to pre-order the
book is I had already been spending
months practicing getting customers to
pre-order the book the first people who
pre-ordered the Lean Startup pre-ordered
it a full year 12 months before the book
was published when it didn't even have
an Amazon listing yet in fact I just
signed the publishing contract I
personally took people's money alive
through PayPal I had a web page where
you could go and you could pre-order the
book I didn't even really know what the
book was gonna be about yeah it
certainly hadn't been written yet but
look who you're talking to right so I
felt I would be a hypocrite if I didn't
do that so as your MVP it was my MVP and
if zero people had pre-ordered the book
at that point I would have called a full
halt for the whole process because I
would have been doomed I would have
known at least then I would have known I
was doing but so I had been practicing
testing constantly both the marketing
message of the book and the content of
the book together with test readers I
mean I didn't even know how much to
charge people for the book because you
know in publishing you don't know how
much the book is gonna cost and see how
many pages it is because of course
that's gonna be the most efficient
market bearing press makes up a number
of pages right so it was it was a very
strange thing to do to be like hi
I want you to something really
irrational I want you to pre-order a
book a year before it comes out only
someone really crazy would do that but
that's the definition of an early
adopter people who wanted to be part of
building but sing into a movement and
how many readers yeah what's that and by
the time the book came out we'd sold I
think ten thousand Wow so a lot by
publishing standards I know if I do with
the money yeah this is a boy talk about
don't get me started on publishing what
a backwards industry no I listen for the
record for the record I'm a very happy
author I love my publisher things are
gone great for me okay but this is not a
good system I had to pay people to
manually enter those orders into Amazon
and Barnes and Noble by hand in order to
get them to count as official orders for
all the publishing you know analytics
and rankings and stuff so there was
actually this massive you know manual
ridiculous process of taking legit it's
not cheating we're taking real orders
from people take their money pay the
Commission pay somebody to enter the
thing onto Amazon again because there's
no good ap is and that the whole system
is anyway
you know okay the hardest part of
getting this software but I wrote
software to do all this testing and in
fact you can go at leand st and you can
see all the experiments we ran it's all
public now the hardest part of getting
the software written was convincing the
engineers who are working on it that
this is the way that publishing really
works so I would explain like bla bla
bla this is the spec of the thing I
wonder it onmy like what wouldn't it be
better if it worked this other way it's
like yeah that's right it would that
would be better a good job you found a
better way to do publishing anyway this
is how it actually works though so it
doesn't matter that you could and and
engine just couldn't take it it was so
irrational like we're gonna have people
for to take the money have them enter
would it be better if we integrated with
some API I'm like yes it would yeah
alright well enough about publishing
yeah sorry about that so so dangerous
topic this idea has gotten so big and I
mean there's it's it's Harvard Business
School has done courses on it in the
entrepreneur program Todd Park this new
CTO of the United States did a has
brought Lean Startup philosophies to the
US government and calls them Lean
Startup yeah I mean this is this is even
bigger than a best-seller normally goes
what do you what do you fathom is behind
that enthusiasm listen no one is more
surprised than I am I mean really I'm an
engineer guy used to write code for a
living and how I do this for a living
it's like what is this I don't know I
mean honestly I really don't think it's
about me I really think that there is an
incredible hunger in the world for
better ideas of an entrepreneurship
people have started to get the memo that
are like the future of our civilization
depends on getting good at
entrepreneurship because boring jobs are
obsolete there aren't going to be that
there's no reason for human beings to do
routine work anymore
and any of you watch been paying
attention all day like every form of
routine work is gonna be automated and
so the question is what are people gonna
do like what what are we gonna do that
like we have more productive capacity in
our you know first world civilization
than we know what to do with what are
the people who are responding to to the
Lean Startup the same people who need
jobs no well not directly I'm Anna this
is not like you know everyone who's
becoming Annapurna someone who's laid
off but the attractiveness of doing what
they call traditional career path
compared to becoming an entrepreneur is
really changed because people who went
to go work in supposedly safe industries
and supposedly safe
companies take a regular job I often
call them involuntary entrepreneurs
it doesn't say entrepreneur on their
business card it's just all of the
sudden the things they used to do that
worked great don't work anymore and now
what am I supposed to do so that problem
is really endemic and the state of the
art ideas about entrepreneurship are
really bad I mean they're just they're
just they don't work I mean they didn't
work
we wouldn't need this so so is that
partly why I mean what I so your book is
is leading the charge but you know Reid
Hoffman has the startup of you I mean
there are all sorts of there's a whole
kind of startup industry that's yeah
that's kind of evolved and and is what
is resonating with that term what is so
powerful about that idea well first of
all startup the kind of being a startup
goes through fad cycles you may have
noticed and we are in to call it you
know go my george RR martin theme and
we're in summer but winter is coming
always tell entrepreneurs be ready
winter is coming because this
entrepreneurship becomes cool and not
cool when we go through these cycles and
and you know sells a lot of magazines
and i'll you know i'm often it's great i
understand why that happens but but i
think despite that noise there really is
a deep underlying transition in our
economy from the age of industrial work
to an age of entrepreneurial work i
think that is that's happening
everywhere you look you know I call it
the going back to our friend Karl Marx
right this is not the ownership of the
means of production it is the renter
ship of the means of production if you
have a credit card and 50 bucks you can
rent the means of production and you can
today you can have any kind of software
thing you want built any kind of hosting
access distribution but soon enough any
physical thing you want manufactured for
very they're in very low volumes at very
low cost no capital investment required
so we're move that's you know this is
not capitalism but something new and we
need a management system that can cope
with that reality and we don't have one
yet and so what we have developed in the
startup I really think of as the tip of
the iceberg but the very beginnings of a
movement towards a management science of
entrepreneurship and that's that's what
we need Bradley alright well we're gonna
take some questions so if we get the
mics roving and the hands up we will
make connections as necessary so why
they do that so so I want to
two examples because because we haven't
touched on any examples so so there's
some there's some the scrutiny that this
idea is getting now is it so popular is
well okay show me the proof that this
works some of the proof is actually the
way to make a viable company what I mean
we've talked about them but what are the
what are these accessories to your mind
well we have to be super careful here
whenever you hear a pundit or
professional expert speaking this is the
part where they often go off the rails
because there's an incredible temptation
your incentive as a professional expert
just who everybody and it's to say
things that sound good that's it that's
the whole incentive whether they're true
or not doesn't matter so what sounds
good is to be like every great company
you already admire they basically did
Lean Startup but they didn't know it so
Apple Google South we'd every business
book it's like Apple Google Southwest
Airlines in Walmart I'll do this thing
and so I try that Bose but says that one
now Zappos is good apples is my book as
by the way as several other companies um
it's really challenging so I try hard
not to be like that company's a Lean
Startup that companies I let the
entrepreneur speak for themselves and
speak about the specific techniques that
they've used really effectively so if
you look at kind of the famous examples
of a pivot that was executed
intentionally not by accident as a
crisis but intentionally you can look at
you know a company like Groupon or a
company in the news these days Instagram
if you want to look at examples of the
Minimum Viable Product that's why we
talk about Zappos you know they put
sneakers you know online by taking
pictures at a local shoe store and then
you know being like hey if anyone buys
these shoes we'll just go walk to the
shoe store buy the shoe and mail it to
the customer and be able to test a
Minimum Viable Product but the really
good examples and you know the case
studies that I really admire in the book
are companies you've never heard of
because they're just starting this whole
thing is three years old so it's way too
early to really have the like you know
blockbuster super successes we're just
now starting to see companies like
Instagram that were influenced by these
idea young enough to have been
influenced by these ideas in their
formative days you know have the kind of
success that they've had you know
companies like Dropbox but you know that
this it remains to be seen really which
of these ideas will prove to be the most
impactful over the long term so so I try
not to get too overheated too excited
about it all right we will see
no hands yet stump the audience it's
awesome we do have we do have a question
from Twitter though education
recommendations for mid-career non
entrepreneur non entrepreneurs whose
boring jobs are about to go so basically
people that's sad that's a sad question
yeah
listen this is a sad phenomenon I mean
think this is deeply sad that we have
people doing work that shouldn't be done
doesn't need to be done anymore it's not
fit for human consumption
this work and we all have friends and
colleagues that do work every day that's
like really crushing and not you know
maybe doesn't doesn't need to be done
and so yeah I mean first the number one
recommendation for the person who's in
that situation is just to admit that
that's what's happening and start to
experiment with different things that
actually try to measure your own sense
of progress by how much value you create
for customers and try to do this kind of
experimental thinking the same
recommendation though by the way goes
for the people who are to blame for the
situation which are the people that
employ those people I mean I think it's
a criminally negligent waste of human
potential to employ someone in a boring
job that's it's got to stop
so people who run organizations that are
trying to become more entrepreneurial
like number one recommendation there is
just to have some people in your
organization whose business card
actually says entrepreneur on it I start
to admit that here's someone whose job
description is we don't know exactly
what they should do we don't know what
the next big thing their job is to
figure it out and to kind of acknowledge
that as a career path as a kind of
management that needs to get done that's
you know that's really important all
right we have one here my question is
president company not included but are
we rewarding failure too much I mean
what happened to the old days where a
few seems like all the successful
startups are people who failed a couple
times before and now they now they
succeeded and I'm just wondering um you
know early in earlier days if you didn't
make it the first time that was it
survival of the fittest yeah we're
rewarding failure not enough actually I
take the opposite point of view in fact
if you look at the number one thing you
know when people are trying to emulate
Silicon Valley and in other regional
clusters like the number one issue you
have to get over is
in Britt like people talk about oh it's
great to everyone wants to embrace
failure as a trendy thing but the
question is what does a productive
failure look like like it's only a
productive failure if you learned
something really important from it and
that is if you look at like when VCS
invest in failed entrepreneurs you know
what we want what VCS want is to find an
entrepreneur who learned something
critical on somebody else's dime right
that's like you know free stuff for you
so what we have to do is embrace
productive failure and the Lean Startup
a method of it is actually designed to
engineer more productive failures faster
because if we know we're gonna have to
fail and pivot on the way to success
let's just get it over with as soon as
possible instead of having it happen at
the last minute you know in a crisis
environment but let's do it by design
intentionally but how does it how does
it work for a company like I mean I know
you're working now with major
corporations nordstrom's yeah and others
how does it work inside a company like
that those those companies are so
remarkably risk-averse yeah and that's
the problem and so how do they do it I
mean is it Dan's 10% time solution or
that listen I endorse that totally in
fact we did something called hack week
at the end of every iteration in my last
company we'd actually take a whole week
and just tell people work on whatever
they wanted so I mean I do think that's
very important but most big companies
are actually drowning in good ideas what
Dan didn't tell you is that if you look
at the like most common outcome of
people tinkering around on something you
know uncommitted work in a big company
the most common outcome is they wind up
having to quit the company start their
own startup and make a lot of money
which is great for the entrepreneur but
not so great for the parent company well
you know if you read the literature on
the innovators dilemma and all the
theory of disruptive innovation not to
be obviously very relevant we're talking
about today the problem is that it's
hard for companies to really
commercialize that stuff so we believe
that in the least art of movement that
if you carve out some of your budget not
a lot but some for internal
entrepreneurs and you create the right
structure around them and hold them
accountable in the right way they can
thrive and so I tell one of the stories
from since I was talking about Intuit
tell a story in the book of a product
called snapped tax which is one of those
mobile phone products that a team
created it into it you know five person
team not fancy entrepreneurship in the
outside five regular employees of Intuit
came to get
with this product where you could
literally take a picture with your
smartphone of your w-2 and fill out you
do your taxes in 15 minutes from your
phone I mean that's a really cool
disruptive innovation and yet it
competes with into its flagship products
it's like classic innovators dilemma
this should be impossible but when you
talk to that team about how they did it
they describe this island of freedom
that they had been given to run these
experiments they only had to report to
management when they had something new
to report they weren't asked to give
updates all the time they were and if
you look at the metrics they were held
accountable - like the system was set up
really well and I remember a very
notable moment when I was interviewing
them for the book I said well where did
the island of freedom come from and
they're like huh I don't know never
thought about that good question so we
need good question that's that's the
that's the only question people want to
know the answer to who reading my book I
had to go talk to their manager in there
man and eventually if I we walk your way
up the hierarchy you find someone in
senior leadership who realized that
creating those platforms for
experimentation is the key to leadership
in big companies in the 21st century
that's the same realization that Todd
Park has had in the US government and
they can do it it like the Center for
Medicare what's your Excuse I think
about it yeah all right well very good
joint please join me in thanking Eric
Ries oh thank you very much thank you